in 2015 we saw two fantastic hopeful
breakthroughs for humanity first the
adoption of the sustainable development
goals the collective universal plan for
Humanity to eradicate hunger good
economic development good health within
global environmental targets secondly
after twenty-one years of negotiations
we adopted the legally binding Paris
agreement all nations in the world
keeping global warming under two degrees
Celsius aiming at 1.5 degrees Celsius
today few years down the line we're
still in the hand-waving business now I
think it's time to step back one step
and recognize that I wonder if the world
leaders really knew what they signed the
General Assembly three years ago these
are universal aspirational
transformational goals for inclusive
prosperous humanity on a stable Earth
System but there are underlying problems
we have inherent contradictions between
these goals whether the risk of pursuing
one favorite goal at the expense of
others take for example goal eight on
decent work and economic growth if we
continue doing that by exploiting
natural resources and burning fossil
fuels it will be impossible to reach
goal thirteen three years down the line
we simply must admit we're seeing
limited action to really really address
this as an inclusive collective
Universal package now this requires us
to step back one step I think we have to
ask ourselves some hard questions do we
have any chance of accomplishing the
sustainable development goals by 2030
are there actually inherent trade-offs
that are not compatible with our current
development paradigm but are there
perhaps synergies where we can really
accelerate change and is it really a
people planet really taking seriously
the social and economic aspirational
goals within the life-support systems on
earth now citizens across the world have
starting to recognize that we face
in global rising environmental risks in
fact that a stable planet is a
prerequisite to have good human
wellbeing on earth we need to define a
safe operating space on a stable Earth
System and the planetary boundary
framework was introduced by the
scientific community in 2009 to do
exactly that it has now been widely
embraced across the world in policy
business and communities as a framework
for sustainable development in the
Anthropocene so this slide really shows
the framework with the nine
environmental processes that regulates
the stability of the earth system
providing a safe operating space we will
have a high chance of having good human
well-being and prosperity and equity if
we move into the ellos zone we enter a
dangerous uncertainty zone and into the
red we have a high likelihood of
crossing tipping points that could take
us irreversibly away from the ability of
the earth system to provide social and
economic well-being for Humanity now we
can today
scientifically quantify these boundaries
providing us a stable earth system for
Humanity but we have to go beyond this
and recognize the sustainable
development goals if we really want to
seriously accomplish them must now occur
within this safe operating space we need
to achieve SDGs within PBS but dear
friends not even this is enough we need
to recognize that sustainable
development goals is 12 years away it's
only a milestone it is the bullseye that
we need to go through and zoom ourselves
towards transformations where we can
have a good future to all co-citizens on
earth 9 billion plus within a stable
Earth System in 2050 and beyond this is
a quest and in order to really explore
this and not have only opinions about it
we gather the scientific community the
best thinkers and modelers and started
to develop a completely new complex
systems dynamic model the earth 3 model
building on models that have been around
for the last 50 years and here it is
this is a fantastic piece of work this
has a climate module a biosphere modular
global economic model it has algorithms
it has the whole room of fantastic
accomplishments this is what turns a
scientist on I mean isn't it just a
beautiful piece of work and I just love
to spend the whole evening walking this
through with you but I'll make it as a
point it I I cannot do that
in fact the only thing I can do with you
is just to assure you that this is the
first time it's done nobody has ever
tried to really analytically combine the
sustainable development goals with
planetary boundaries and we were able to
find patterns and really convergent
trends that gives us a lot of confidence
in our ability to now project economic
development resource use from water an
energy population growth income per
person it along these consistent and
systemic pathways so the first time we
have a robust opportunity to really
explore the futures of ability of
attained the SDGs
within PBS now how do we do this well
look at this but here you have the data
coming from real world calibrated
through 1970 2015 hundred thousand data
points around the world building on
seven regions ability of really picking
on all these sustainable development
calls now one example of how we
calibrated this here you have for
sustainable development goals on
eradicating poverty health education and
food and here you have in the bubbles
the seven regions in the world how they
move up until 2015
in our empirical observations in
relation to GDP per capita giving these
universal convergent trends which
enabled us to create rajesh regressions
that could make us able to do
simulations into the future all the way
until 2050 showing the ability along the
lines here to attain the SDGs and the
SDGs now so this gave us the opportunity
of doing several scenarios testing
different possible futures
business-as-usual global transformations
investment schemes and business
different governance options policies
finance really to explore how can the
future look like
in our ability to attain the SDGs within
PBS and the results I can
you really surprised us and this would
be the first time that's shown it should
actually not even be referenced outside
of this room now it actually is
presented along two axes the y-axis here
shows our ability to stay within
planetary boundaries the higher up the
closer you are to the safe operating
space and the x axis are the sustainable
development goals the further to the
right the more of the SDGs
we fulfill we all want to be in the
upper right hand corner the safe and
just world for the future now the point
you see there is 1980 we were in a
situation where we actually weren't in a
safe operating space but not meeting so
many of the SDGs
here's the trend up until 2015 so this
is the conventional world which is
actually delivering on increasing number
of SD G's lifting millions of people out
of poverty but doing it at the expense
of the safe operating space on earth now
this is the scenario business as usual
into the future if we just move on as
today we will be able to deliver on some
of the SDGs but we'll do it at the
expense of the stability of your system
now what if we go faster on economic
growth and really a lie on 1% increase
per year of income and an even tripling
of the world economy by 2050 that would
give us the following trajectory we
would yes go a little bit further on SDG
accomplishments but still at the expense
of the risk of destabilizing the planet
but what if we really go harder what if
we increase our ability to deliver on
our promises by 30 percent across all
sectors in society from climate to our
trade agreements a harder scenario would
take us a little bit better but still
we're failing on the SDGs
and we are not accomplishing a safe
operating space for humanity so this
really led us to a quite disappointing
conclusion that we will actually if even
if we go conventional futures fail on
the SDGs and transgress planetary
boundaries we need some radical thinking
we need to go into a transformative
disrupt the future
where we start thinking outside of the
box
the modeling and engagement and
dialogues enable us to identify five
transformations that could actually
potentially take us there
the first one is to cut emissions by
half every decade along the scientific
pathway to Paris
doubling investments in renewable energy
creating a global energy democracy
allowing us to meet several of the SDGs
the second is a rapid shift towards
sustainable food systems investing in
one percent per year sustainable
intensification and really moving
towards implementing and investing in
solutions that we already have available
today the third is really to shift our
development paradigm and learn from many
of the developing countries that have
moved very fast what if we could have an
economic growth such as in China while
doing it within environmental parameters
of an ecological civilization fourth a
redistribution of wealth what if we
could share that 10% richest could not
allow themselves to amass more than 40%
maximum of national income a drastic
redistribution of wealth reforming the
ability of equity across regions and
finally fifth a radical increase in more
education health access to work
contraception investing largely in women
across the world allowing us to deliver
on STDs on gender equality inequality
economics and urban development now if
we would push ourselves across all these
five we tested this and it would give us
an amazing journey towards the safe and
just operating space on earth it shows
us that even with a conservative
empirically based complex system
dynamics model we are at a state where
we can actually think of transformations
over the next 12 years and beyond that
can take us up into the safe operating
space and deliver an aspirational social
and economic goals this is actually
quite uplifting despite the fact that
we're not moving along this trajectory
so in summary we now three years into
the operational delivery on the SDGs
must draw a line and conclude that were
not doing
on our promises and not only that we're
rolling the risks of future generations
having an even tougher ability because
the risk of pushing their system beyond
tipping points in fact we are facing
even a risk of a hothouse earth where we
will undermine and create geopolitical
instabilities that could actually make
life even more tough for billions of
people on earth this in all honesty
really really scares me but that's also
why I'm standing here tonight because
the window of success is still open the
earth system is still resilient she is
still providing us with ecosystem
services and functions that can allow us
a transition back into safe operating
space but we need radically different
thinking we need to see this as an
incredible wake-up call but also
opportunity for transformative change
where we shift gears and really start
thinking of the SDGs as a transformative
agenda within a safe operating space on
earth in other words we can build a safe
and just world we just have to really
really get on with it and let's do it
thank you
[Applause]